in terms of criticism here is how I deal
with it and this is having written 32
books the first time I asked people to
read my work I say tell me only what you
love about it and they say you know I
love Jeremiah I love that you sent to
this book in bushwick I love whatever it
is and then I get all excited I go back
and write more and then the next time I
say asked me three questions and then
the three questions are why does he get
killed why do they fall in love why does
he end up in the witness protection
program whatever the questions they have
that makes me go back and realize I
haven't explained stuff enough and write
more it really is fragile right when you
first put your words out into the world
and for someone to jump on them and
start critiquing or criticizing them
right off the bat can be devastating so
for even for me at this stage it has to
be incremental and and always starting
with praise lots and lots of praise and
then getting to the nitty-gritty and so
I I think it's important to show your
work to people you trust and love and I
think it's important to read your work
out loud to hear it and here where it
feels safe and unsafe even with my
editor when i get my manuscript back
from her i go through the whole
manuscript and read all the places where
she's like wow love this brilliant you
know awesome or and and all of those
praises kind of get me ready for her to
ask the bigger questions and it's
important that the criticism be
constructive because otherwise its
destructive right you want to just throw
the book away and so the criticism
should be the kind of critiquing that
asked questions asked bigger questions
why does this happen i'm curious about
where this girl is going at the end of
this piece of dialogue what were you
intending for the reader to get so that
kind of thing that it's so it doesn't
feel make you feel so long
honourable writing is such a process and
I think that's sometimes aspiring
writers don't realize what a process it
is from the moment you have a brilliant
idea to when you get to the point and
that book completely falls apart and
every single book you write you have a
brilliant idea it falls apart every
single book and then you have to start
scaffolding and building the story again
and starting to ask yourself the big
questions about what this book is trying
to say and how is it trying to say it
and what are these characters want and
how are they going to get what they want
so that's the process and then the next
process is going out into the world with
the story and getting that feedback and
deciding who you're going to ask and
what you're looking for in the feedback
and what you're in goal is for the story
do you want to publish it or do you want
something that your parents will love so
you can give it to them as a anniversary
present or what it what is it you want
this book to be and how does it fit into
the world of literature how does it fit
in to the stuff that's already out there
so you have to be a reader right you
can't be a writer without being a reader
and I think that's another mistake young
writers make I've met so many poets who
are like well I don't read poetry I just
write in are so many people who are
trying to write realistic fiction that
are only reading fantasy it's it's just
unrealistic to not know the genre you're
writing in side of so then you have the
people critiquing your work and you get
to choose who they are you get to choose
how you want that feedback to come back
to you some people will give their work
to 10 people are some people will trust
a workshop I I for one have been in
workshops and I haven't always trusted
them because a lot of times I'm the only
person of color in it so suddenly I'm
to explain to a lot of people who are
not people of color my experience and
having to justify my experience and and
that's not helpful to me so think about
who who the people are you're asking to
share you you're asking to read your
work and what you want from them if I'm
writing a book about someone who's
transgendered and which i'm not going to
do because i don't know enough about
that story but hypothetically i would
want someone who's had that experience
to be able to help me negotiate and
again show me where do I get this right
where do I get this wrong where do my
own bias where does my own bodies come
into the story but you do have to be
able to be vulnerable with your work at
some point but for me I like to build a
nice thick skin before I get to that
point of feeling vulnerable